hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
my bonus video I'm gonna do a history
for Maester Aemon on the show very
famous Targaryen but not one that we've
spent a lot of time in the show with
just careful for spoilers on everything
that has happened on the show so far
most of the history we're gonna cover is
stuff that's done in like the expanded
works so there's actually been three
known Targaryen that have been named
Amon the first was the second son of
King jaehaerys the first he was the
fourth king of Westeros his
great-grandfather being Aegon the
conquerer the second person to be named
Damon was the son of Visser e's the
second he ended up joining the
Kingsguard
that was around a hundred and sixty-two
years before events on season one of the
show then the third person was our amon
maester aemon our Amon was born about a
hundred years before events on the show
like whenever season one picks up he's
about a hundred years old
so right now you know in the Canon he's
about a hundred two hundred three years
old it depends on how long do you think
it's been since season one started it's
really been like not more than three
years he's the third son of King Makar
Targaryen the first funfact though as
old as he is he's not the oldest person
that we've seen on the show that's the
Bloodraven
even if you don't read the books you
probably know him as the three-eyed
Raven or Brynden rivers he's this guy
here that's been chilling out with Brant
underneath the heart treat teaching
brand all about being a green seer of
course they're not in the show this
season so we'll probably won't see him
again till next year
the Bloodraven is about twenty three
years older than maester aemon Amon was
born right at the end of the first
Blackfyre rebellion his father is the
son of the person who won the Blackfyre
rebellion prince Darrin even though
their side won a man's father maker
didn't become King till Amon was about
23 years old remember this is an era in
Westeros when the Targaryen bloodline
proliferated their family had prospered
for almost like 200 years but because
there can be only one nuclear family
sitting on the Iron Throne at a time you
wind up with like scores and scores of
cousins who can never rise above the
level of prince in the extended family
so one king shitload of princes and
princesses the way titles are passed on
in Westeros are very similar to the
British nobility you know a couple minor
changes maker had six children including
maester aemon all born long before he
ever became King because a man's grand
father Prince Darrin ii already had a
few grown children each with heirs of
their own and because the kingdom had
just survived the Blackfyre rebellion
Amon was sent to the Citadel to train as
a maester just to avoid another war of
succession because there were so many
possible heirs so many people in the
line of succession for those wondering
how maester aemon is related to Daenerys
he's like her great-uncle Daenerys his
father Aerys ii the Mad King is the
grandson of maester aemon's younger
brother Aegon the fifth so they share a
lot of the same blood although
technically anyone born with the
Targaryen name would be said to have the
blood of the Dragon because Amon started
training at the Citadel at such a young
age I mean like really young age I think
he was like 10 years old he finished
forging his master's chain at 19 that'd
be like getting your PhD or becoming a
doctor at the age of 19 I've already
done a video about the Citadel and
becoming a maester so I'll include a
link in the description but essentially
you form links in a chain that represent
areas of mastery of study for example
the most common area of study is raven
wreaths the birds that they use is the
express post office that link is made of
black iron you know very common metal
the rarest one is the Valyrian steel
link that represents mastery in the area
of magic in the occult most of the arch
masters in the Citadel frown on the
study of magic with the exception of
Marwyn the mage who has risen to the
level of archmaester he is something of
an outcast in the leadership of the
Citadel and it's also someone that the
show is cut out so I don't know if we're
gonna see him in season six vme we might
he's a really interesting character but
Amon after he forged his chain went on
to serve an unknown Lord until his
father called him to the red Keith to
serve his family so Amon who is a
maester now was offered a seat on the
small Council but he denied because it
was already a grand maester and the
grand maesters always guaranteed a seat
on the small Council so he chose to
serve his family at Dragonstone
Dragonstone at this time was held by a
man's older brother Darren the drunken
but you know as you can imagine from the
dubious title he was kind of an asshat
he died from the pox which he contracted
from a shortly after a maester
aemon started serving in the Dragonstone
after his brother died Amon just went
back to the Citadel to serve there
around that time maester aemon's in his
mid 30s so he gets called to King's
Landing for a great counsel to deter
who's going to be the next king because
his older brother left an heir but it's
a really weak choice so there's a big
mess in the line of succession so all
the Lords of the kingdom you know met to
decide who should be the next king they
decided that Maester Aemon was the
strongest choice so they offered him the
crown but he passed and the succession
passed to his brother to his younger
brother Aegon the fifth that was
Denise's great-grandfather anytime
there's mass confusion like there's a
big you know WTF over the line of
succession a Great Council can be called
it's only happened a couple times in
history really interesting sidenote on
that if you haven't read world of Ice
and Fire the the history book is is
actually a lot of fun there's a rumor
inside it that implies Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen
Daenerys his older brother masterminded
the tourney of Harrenhal you know the
really infamous one where he won and
gave the blue rose to Lyanna Stark
flipping everyone out that rumor states
it was his original intention to use
that tournament to assemble all the
Lords of the Kingdom and arrange a
shadow Great Council to depose his
father the Mad King the rumor goes on to
state that the Mad King found out about
this and chose to attend the tournament
himself to prevent anyone from plotting
against him it goes on to speculate that
had Rhaegar not died at the Trident you
know by Roberts Warhammer he would have
gone on to openly call a grey Council to
get rid of his father
so if Rhaegar had won Robert's rebellion
they still would have gotten rid of the
Mad King but that's just a theory it's
born out of world of Ice and Fire and a
lot of people don't consider that
official canon even though George R
Martin collaborated on it so take it as
you will you know use it in theory
crafting as you want
back to maester aemon though so after
this Great Council you know he passed
the succession to his younger brother
Aegon v he took the black and went to
the Nights Watch his reasoning was is
that you know by taking the black he
could prevent anyone for trying to use
him in a plot against his brother so he
was trying to protect his family by
removing himself from the equation
whenever he actually took the journey to
go to the wall for the first time his
brother Aegon gave him the special honor
guard one of the people that escorted in
there was the Bloodraven Brynden rivers
he of course went on to become a future
Lord Commander then went on to become
the last green seer in the three-eyed
Raven remember maester aemon's in his
mid-30s right about now so that make the
Bloodraven somewhere in his late 50s so
they're actually they're not that old
it said that during his later years
Maester Aemon corresponding with rhaegar
targaryen or rather it was Rhaegar that
sent Ravens tenth sent messages to
maester aemon just asking him for advice
or telling him what was going on with
his family I know there are a whole lot
of theories about you know what Rhaegar
did with Lyanna stark and the mystery
snow baby they may have had that that's
all still theory territory but it's
possible that if Rhaegar did something
like that he would have told maester
aemon in a message Amon said that during
his time at the Nights Watch he was
tempted to break his vows three times
one of those was during Robert's
rebellion so you know theory craft about
that as you will we might not ever find
out what's in those messages Rhaegar
sent to Amon
you know unless he may have kept them
somewhere in the Nights Watch library if
only we had someone on the show that
reads a lot inside the library
generally speaking you know after the
Bloodraven I would say mace dream is
probably the greatest asset that the
people at the Nights Watch have for
fighting White Walkers when you're the
maester at the Nights Watch you have
nothing but time like there's not a lot
to do when you're not healing people so
think of the accumulated knowledge that
they have in that library I mean Sam
wells only just started to touch it my
hope is is that the show goes on you
know Samwell will just keep pouring
through that library and learn things
for maester aemon or from previous
maesters anything that will help them
learn more about the White Walkers I
love that Stannis is really down for
that - like he's so happy that Samwell
is reading so much it just stands to
reason that you know if the show is
going to be explaining White Walkers to
us it's gonna be via that library
Samwell learning stuff you guys can let
me know though do you think that maester
aemon has hidden some secrets in that
library anything about the history of
the kingdom or what happened during
Robert's rebellion or even anything
about White Walkers and don't forget
episode 7 tonight I'll post my video
after it airs be sure to subscribe to
get it I'll be doing a new round of the
giveaway to all you book readers are
really gonna like episode 7 it's gonna
be a lot of fun so while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
last week's episode and you can click
here to learn all about the Targaryen
restoration on the show thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you